[Applaudissements]
j'ai tourné alors vous avez commencé à
faire des sketches dans le marais avec
guillaume canet et vous avez vous avez a
officié pendant trois ans comme
assistant magicien oui ce que vous savez
tout à faire des tours de magie ou pas
du tout eu
non mais moi j'étais assistant donc je
me faisais coupée en trois c'est ça je
m'étais je sais plus je mettais ma
rasoir dans la bouche
je coupais des bouts de papier je
disparaissais de si nous savions qu'il
était assistant régis et où il a été
assistant magicien for web et vous savez
qu'ils soient au tac à un magicien
important dans le monde de la magie
forcément on peut pas être magicien
important dans le monde de la chanson
et vous avez un fantasme c'est allé sur
la lune et sauter à l'élastique à cette
histoire
bah c'est pas aller sur la lune pour
sauter en est là ça n'a pas du tout
l'intention non plus dans le bain en
plus âge j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
cosmonaute
ouais ouais elles mêmes sur la lune dans
la lutte c'est une chose sur la lune
marché sur la lune dans la vie mais vous
ne vous emmèneriez qui s'est reconnu et
une proposition je parle de vraiment
intentionnellement on se connaît
tellement ouais mais bon ça n'empêche
pas en crémerie plus non plus je connais
des gens d'ici depuis très longtemps et
ça nous empêche pas de fricoter n'est ce
pas thierry moreau oui nous sommes
ensemble alors je vous faire un petit
quizz île déserte